foreign
is in Cookeville Tennessee not too far
away from us Lori how can we help
uh yes I just wondering how we can not
continue to lose money so we can stay
retired oh okay walk us through this how
old are you guys
um I will next month be 62 my husband a
month after will be 61. okay and are you
both working are you both fully retired
no no we've been we've been fully
retired since we 54 and 55. wow and I
was yes yes
have you been bringing any income at all
no no so you're just pulling from your
nest egg
well when we first started for the first
year we had some
um yes but just from our nest egg from
investing what was the total Nest Egg
when you retired and what is it today
it was a little over a million when we
started and we're at 1 million 20 right
now we've lost like 300 000 in the last
few years okay yeah you said we keep
losing money what did you mean by that
um our investments keep going down what
are they currently allocated in
uh stocks mutual funds January we just
got each um a hundred thousand um
annuities but that's all part of the
um total okay I know you're working with
a financial advisor right now yeah yes
absolutely and we are have an
appointment to see what ones that was
recommended by Dave Ramsey
um on April 6 to see what his plan is
yeah my guess is one of our smartvestor
Pros which is our financial advisors we
recommend across the country they
probably wouldn't have put you in an
annuity
now most of them are are Just Junk
there's only one very specific scenario
that would make sense for that but as
far as you losing money what is a
percentage that you've lost because
everyone has lost money 23 okay 23
that's about right I mean the S P 500
lost 18 in 2023 and so everyone across
the board has seen about a 20 25 dip in
their retirement accounts which hurts
okay so we're not I mean I know other
people have lost money but yeah okay
well that's not outrageous Yeah it's
unoutrageous you're not alone and then
remember we're telling other people who
are not in retirement age who aren't
drawing from it just hang on you know
it's a roller coaster don't get off the
ride that's when you really get hurt in
your situation the question that I've
got uh is what what is your fixed uh
budget do you have a fixed budget you
guys are really disciplined with and
what are you essentially drawing
absolutely what are you drawing
a year
um 65 000 we are completely debt free
and have been for years we only have one
vehicle
um so you're drawing 65 000 from the
retirement account about six and a half
percent a year what is your Social
Security
mine will be eight hundred and twelve
dollars and that will be basically our
cost of living raise for you know
everything that's gone up that's right
you're not even you haven't even started
drawing that yet correct not till June
my my first tech comes in June well my
husband's the following year which will
be fourteen hundred dollars okay
so that's good perspective to have my
parents in a very similar situation you
know they're they're they have no debt
and they they can truly live off of
Social Security and so their retirement
is just great yeah and you guys have no
debt I assume
none love it okay I'm gonna throw
something out here Georgia and I I I
just think that retirement
is overrated and what I mean by that is
I said this on my show today I said all
the time you know I I think we're
created to work and and I think that you
can slow down yes have a lot of freedom
yes but I wonder in a situation like
this where they go you know what what
could we do for 15 20 30 hours a week
they get to choose they don't have to go
to work but if there's something that
they enjoy doing that can actually make
some money I like that I like going back
to work at your pace at your choice Lori
I really do to offset some of this well
well we you know we live from we live
far away from family for a long time and
we have a camper we bought for nine
thousand dollars so we camp a lot near
family with friends and the things we
enjoy doing is just building things and
you know hiking so we don't just sit
um
we're healthy yeah but my point is if
you like building things maybe I'd make
a little money on the side building
things and Ken's point is to alleviate
some of the stress because the key when
the market is down is you want to take
out as little as possible yes because
what you're dealing with here something
called the sequence of returns risk what
that means is if you take the same chunk
out this year while the Market's down
it's going to hurt your ability to grow
that money that would have grown in the
future with compound interest and so you
it'll shorten your time span to live off
that million if you take the same amount
and so what you want to do is be as
conservative as possible while the
markets are down like this so only take
out what you need if you don't need all
65 000 take out forty thousand and that
will help this money uh to to live
longer as you live longer and so that's
what Ken's saying if you can bring in 20
grand this year from part-time work that
you love yeah that allows you to take
out 40 Grand from retirement instead of
60.
I guess our other our question is should
we be more in mutual funds do we have
too many stocks and mutual funds because
I would stick to mutual funds personally
which are highly allocated towards you
know equities and stocks and So within
that yes but I would not be investing in
any single stocks at your stage of the
game okay over any one stage of the game
I just I don't do any single stocks
personally I don't do any crypto I'm all
mutual funds index funds giant piles of
stocks with the top companies that's
what you're looking for yeah
okay and our smartvester pros and we
want you to interview two or three of
them okay and and you want to find the
one where you've got a good connection
with it uh with them you want them to be
able to explain things where you
understand so you are making decisions
not them but they're going to walk you
through our investment strategy I think
you guys are going to be in good shape